whenever you're faced with an important
business decision
tap into your core values and remember
why you started this business
before you make a decision otherwise you
could take on a deal or opportunity that
you'll regret for the rest of your life
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help
and i got a question from one of my
youtube viewers thank you youtube guys
named ricky who had a question about
business expansion he wrote in to say hi
evan
i have a small produce stand i sell
things like corn tomatoes cucumbers i
love this business but i can't think of
any way of expanding it
i'm unsure of how i could possibly make
more money and grow this small roadside
stand into a bigger business
thank you for reading i really
appreciate your informative videos ricky
thanks for the question and congrats
on on what you've done so far for
reaching out but you didn't tell me
anything about
what's unique about your business what
makes you special
you start off saying i have a small
produce stand i sell things as corn
tomatoes cucumbers it's boring
there's tons of those guys you want to
expand your business you have to know
what sets you apart
for me to give you advice i have to know
what's different about you
what you stand for what makes you unique
there's a lot of ways to grow this
business
you could create your own product line
you could try to launch a retail retail
store
you could have multiple stands on
different roads
there's a lot of ways to grow this but i
don't know what makes you special
and why you started this business
whenever you're faced with an important
business growth opportunity
and there's multiple ways to go and
you're confused
the clarity comes from looking at why
you started your business and what your
core values are
i'll give you a quick example companies
come to me all the time wanting me to
to represent them to pitch their
products
and most of the time i say no because i
don't use your product
and these are companies that you would
recognize i'm not going to name names
but brand name companies that you would
recognize
call me up and say evan we love what
you're doing we're trying to reach more
entrepreneurs
we want you to say our company is the
greatest and pitch our product
this is an easy decision for me my core
value is i love helping entrepreneurs
right you hear
at the beginning of my videos i believe
that hungry entrepreneurs deserve help
if what i'm doing isn't helping
entrepreneurs i'm not going to feel good
about it
even if it makes me a lot of money i'm
not going to do it because i'm not going
to feel good about it and the end result
is not going to be great
so no i will not pitch your product even
if you're throwing a ton of cash at me
because i don't think it's going to help
people
if i can't firmly stand behind it then
i'm not going to pitch it
and so back to this business growth
opportunity there's a lot of ways to
grow it
and you should be thinking beyond just
one little location
if it's multiple locations if it's a
retail store if you're starting a home
delivery business
whatever it is lots of ways to grow it
but what makes you special
you cannot just be a little side store
on the side of the street selling
cucumbers and corn
there has to be something different and
i think there's there you know every
entrepreneur has that within them
but they don't let it come out they
don't share it they don't put everything
they have into it they don't communicate
that message with people
and as a result you get lost you're just
another guy doing the same thing as
everybody else
every time you're communicating what you
do to anybody
so when ricky's writing into me he
should be writing that right anytime you
write an email to somebody
you got to say what makes you special so
ricky work on it
write back to me i want to hear your new
pitch i don't want to hear
you just have a small produce stand
okay and then from there we can talk
about how to grow this business
i believe you have something there and i
think every entrepreneur has that within
them
they just don't do a good job of
recognizing themselves
and putting it into every piece of
communication that you do
good luck for those of you watching you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below and i'd love to hear from you
please leave a comment under this video
it makes my morning every time when i
see them come in
so thank you guys and i'll see you on
the next episode